we're currently waiting on the Supreme
Court's decision really two decisions
about Donald Trump's tax returns and I'm
hoping to have news about that either
later on in today's program or if not
we'll talk about it tomorrow on the
Friday show with you but we do have a
new Supreme Court decision to talk about
that came out yesterday and if you've
been following the Supreme Court for the
last couple of weeks you might be aware
that we had some reasonable decisions
some correct decisions from my
perspective from the Supreme Court over
the last few weeks but we did not get
that yesterday the Supreme Court has
cited 7 to 2 with the Trump
administration to allow employers to
deny access to employees of free
contraceptive coverage if the reason for
wanting to deny free birth control is
religious in nature and this is mean
listen the the the 72 decision the 7
majority each had buried not all the
same reasons why they were with the
majority but the decision in and of
itself is a huge win for the religious
right and it is a loss for Obamacare as
well it's a loss for secularism and it's
certainly at least a win that the Trump
administration can claim now that this
is one of the few wins that the Trump
administration can claim is part of a
bigger discussion about what is the case
to be made that Trump has accomplished
anything and should be a wreck
re-elected or not not what I almost said
but that is really a case that Donald
Trump has to make that's not a case for
me to make but this is at least
something that went his way the daka
decision not going his way
LGBT discrimination decision not going
his way and the Trump administration has
actually tried a number of different
ways to hurt Obama care with different
regulations one such regulation is that
if you are a religious based employer
you now will be able to say our
employees people who have health
insurance under as a result of working
for us they will no longer be able to
get
free birth control one of the things
that Obamacare said was that birth
control is free to the patient they must
have full coverage of contraceptive
services and products as part of their
health insurance plans houses of worship
including churches temples and mosques
were exempt from that requirement from
the get-go some people were not aware of
that but a lot of nonprofit groups like
schools which could be religiously
affiliated or based hospitals which
could be religiously affiliated or based
were not exempt if you worked for them
they had to through their insurance
coverage that that you are offered as an
employee had to offer contraceptive
services at no cost
some of them objected right away and
they said that goes against our
religious beliefs how are we it is a
violation of our freedom of religion to
say we must allow we must provide no
cost at to the patient of course
contraceptive services when we don't
believe that those should be something
people avail themselves of on the basis
of our religious beliefs in came the
Trump administration and they said we
agree with the religious employers
requiring birth control coverage without
cost burdens the free exercise of
religion they put in place some
exemption rules where employers can say
we opt out their employees can still get
birth control but it wouldn't be free of
a cost through their health insurance
plan now since the Affordable Care Act
requires it what that meant in practice
is that the states where people live
would have to pay and states like
Pennsylvania and New Jersey said hold on
a second if employers are not required
to provide this through their health
insurance we have to pay for it and
that's not fair to us said Pennsylvania
and New Jersey
a lower court agreed with Pennsylvania
and New Jersey that is the decision that
has now been reversed by the Supreme
Court the 7tu to vote in the Supreme
Court had Ruth Bader Ginsburg and Sonia
Sotomayor as the only dissenters
the majority said these restrictions put
in place by the Trump administration are
okay and for me the major takeaway and
what I want to remind you of is that
this is another explanation another way
to remind ourselves that health
insurance should not be tied to
employers period that that's my takeaway
and of course you can fight the legal
battle and that's exactly what the Trump
administration did but at a higher level
health insurance tied to employers is
the wrong direction and the in terms of
how far this goes there is a slippery
slope question here as well I mean if
you look at I don't know Christian
Science Christian Science is very much
against all sorts of medical care would
antibiotics be a legit exemption if they
are religiously based if Christian signs
says listen we run this big Christian
science you know reading room or
whatever they call it and we don't want
to provide antibiotics with we don't
want antibiotics to be so accessible
would that be valid I mean how far does
this go now the estimates are that
somewhere between 70,000 and 126
thousand women are going to lose
contraceptive coverage as a result of
this decision and what this really is is
pointing back to is this is an
administration the Trump administration
that has lost on policy Trump was going
to repeal and replace Obamacare failed
he was gonna build the wall failed he
was gonna fix this fix that fix the
other he's failed on essentially
everything they are now fighting a
culture war remember that Donald Trump
is not religious this is merely
pandering and it is a win on paper for
Donald Trump how much of a big deal he
makes out of this win remains to be seen
but this is a cultural war if you look
at the last six weeks you know the right
loves to accuse the left of fighting a
cultural war the reality is that it's
trump who faced with losing on just
about every policy issue is now talking
about we've got to fight these radical
Marxists mark there's barely any
Marxists and certainly none in positions
of power in the United States this is
about our heritage visa vie monuments
and the Confederate
flag and it's about free speech these
are culture war type battles and again
this you're not really damaging
Obamacare in the sense of removing it
the way he wants to do
you're just making life more difficult
for seventy thousand to a hundred and
twenty six thousand more women and Trump
who is not religious continues to pander
to the religious right through these
types of arguments and regulations so
that's what it all is really about
there's stunning hypocrisy as well
because you block access to birth
control but then do you do you provide
parental leave paid parental leave when
the baby is born
many many employers do not in there
certainly not mandated to etc etc I
think you get the idea but at least on
paper it is a win for the Trump
administration a win that they
desperately need because these wins are
so few and far between you know I hate
it when I'm right about horrible things
I really do but Americans are now the
dangerous disease-carrying foreigners
just like I predicted we would be some
months ago and I hate it I'm not happy
about this I'm not gloating about this
it personally upsets me that this is the
reality much of the world at least for
now is safely returning to normality
friends in Belgium France a lot of
different places
masks required on public transit things
are more spaced out at restaurants but
increasingly unnormal existence is
resuming in countries that have
successfully fought the virus that is
not the case in the United States we are
not allowed to go to many parts of the
world the travel bans which we are known
for our now against us because
coronavirus is raging here the American
right wing is all about banning others
but it is we who are now banned because
we are the danger visitors from 15
different countries can now go to the
European Union not Americans it's too
dangerous
there's too much coronavirus here we've
failed we are on a list so to speak the
American right has been demonizing
others as those who like Tucker Carlson
said on his Fox News program some months
ago immigrants make our country dirtier
and poorer that was Tucker Carlson well
the American right has said it's
foreigners who bring disease the
American right has said we need to stop
them from coming here but now we are the
ones that are too risky for other
countries to let us in as Erika Lee
writes in a Washington Post piece
there's a very long history of tying
foreigners to disease here in the United
States you go back to the 1700s Germans
and yellow fever they were going to
bring yellow fever Irish in the 1800s
they were going to bring cholera so many
examples Chinese immigrants smallpox and
bubonic plague and leprosy Jews and
tuberculosis that's a classic Italians
and polio in the early 1900's Mexicans
to plague typhus and smallpox it's a
very long list and the links between
xenophobia and disease are widespread
they're long lasting and we've seen much
of the same more recently with
coronavirus and so understand that
Chinese flu Wuhan flu come flu as Donald
Trump has repeatedly called it all of
that stuff it's just more of the same
this is not new we've seen this in the
US since the 1700s and of course yeah
the virus originated in China and yet
China lied and yes China should be held
accountable but every country dealt with
a virus that originated in China most
countries dealt with that virus that
originated in China far better than we
did so much better in fact that we are
now banned for many of those countries
it's an embarrassment
the virus is exploding in huge parts of
this country again a single day case
record yesterday I will talk to you
later on by the way Texas now two days
in a row setting it's single day case
death record exactly as we would have
predicted when cases started surging in
mid to late June this has nothing to do
with immigration it has to do with a
late and terrible testing program lack
of a contact hit tracing program botched
and too early reopening z' reluctance to
wear masks in some states and it's now
bleeding into the responsible States too
I've been saying for several weeks now
we're doing great here
in Massachusetts but it can't last
forever when cases are so high in so
many of these other states and indeed
cases and hospitalizations are starting
to trickle up here in Massachusetts it's
only a little bit but it's starting to
happen we are now the disease carrying
foreigners that have to be banned from
other countries and it's embarrassing
and it's horrifying and I hate it but I
understand why countries have to do it
is our weakness ego is our weakness
anti-science sentiment is it
hyperpolarization we won't ever be like
those other countries many of us
believed it won't ever come to that and
now coronavirus has shown that we were
so extraordinarily unprepared and had
failed leadership so now the question is
what do we do do we need another
lockdown do we need like a six-week
coordinated full lockdown if that's what
we need it's never going to happen I
mean you know I'm talking about you
really you don't leave your house
without a mask you really don't go
anywhere other than four essential trips
grocery store or whatever the case may
be and you'd have to do new stimulus
payments like is that what we actually
need now because when you look at 10,000
cases a day in Florida 10,000 cases a
day in Texas you don't get that under
control by saying let's just not go to
bars let's not do indoor dining you just
don't that's not how you get it under
control clearly the summer heat isn't
stopping it clearly it's just not going
to disappear in April the way Donald
Trump and so many others said we are
nowhere near herd immunity but no matter
what happens on that front you've got to
be registered to vote and we have to
remove this administration in November
because no matter what happens between
now and November third we need someone
else at the helm that must happen and so
we're going to talk about polling a
little later let's not take our eye off
the ball when it comes to acting
responsibly day-to-day on coronavirus
let's do it and encourage everybody we
know to do it but when it comes to
removing this failed leader not really
really even a leader we've got a not
lose sight of that and that's
just just four months from now Tuesday
we will be having the third ever David
Pakman show chess tournament you can
register for free at david pakman.com
slash chess hope you'll join us we'll
also have a big one day membership
special on Tuesday July 14th you can be
notified about that simply by signing up
for my newsletter at david pakman.com
let me know what's going on in your
state i'm on twitter at depatment
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are werner
neffenger and yolanda jackson werner and
Yolanda thank you so much for your
support
I very very much appreciated and also
want to say thanks today's longtime
sustaining member of the day that's
Bruce Burns Bruce signed up back in 2015
Bruce has been a member almost five
years and is today's sustainer of the
day grab a membership we have too much
to do today for me to spend much more
time on it but it takes under a minute
at join pakman.com we have a discussion
forum of sorts at on reddit at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
i.t we now have somewhere around 21,000
of our viewers and listeners subscribed
there and there were three posts I
spotted this morning with similar themes
when it comes to the November election
and some of this is reassuring but I
also want to talk about sort of the
cautionary aspects of it so user the
final play down posted only one will be
president I choose
Biden and I'm reassured to some degree
that a lot of the very loud voices that
for months ago were saying Biden's not
progressive enough if it's not Bernie or
not Tulsi or whoever you know yang then
I kind of don't care if it's Trump or
Biden or a lot of those voices I'm not
hearing from anymore and what I am
hearing is you know I now understand the
importance of removing Donald Trump and
I'm glad to see that use their wagon
wheel what had a similar post which was
this election is pretty simple
a majority of Americans are suffering
and sick and tired of Trump's stick and
Biden is a more palatable moderate
alternative
it's very sober right it's not Biden is
the future of the progressive movement
it's we have to remove Donald Trump
that's the take away and I'm sort of to
some degree reassured by seeing this and
then a third post also this one from
wagon wheel what is do you think Trump
has given up the announcement about
leaving the World Health Organization
just seems like a burn it all to the
ground move I'm getting more and more
messages about that which is does Trump
even really want to win is Trump trying
to torpedo his own reelection I think
that it's not a dangerous path to go
down
but it's one that if we go too far down
it could dissuade people from voting and
listen Trump what what we know about
Trump is that he's an extreme narcissist
with significant delusions of grandeur
and I don't believe that in any
conscious way Donald Trump is going to
throw in the towel or not try to win
what I do believe will happen is if
Trump loses he's gonna do what
narcissists do is he's not going to
really accept it as an actual defeat
Trump will say I never really wanted
this anyway I gave you four years I made
the country great again if you want Joe
Biden I'm gonna go I'm still rich I'm
the best businessman I'm gonna build
buildings or whatever else the case may
be he's never going to see it as really
a defeat because he is an extreme
narcissist but I think anybody thinking
Trump's throwing in the towel are not
really going to try to win we are going
to see over the next four months a
significant significant escalation in
Trump's erratic nature and yes he's
going to try to win and every single one
of us has to vote which is why we're
going to talk about polling momentarily
I invite you to join the discussion on
the subreddit at david pakman.com slash
our EDD i.t
we have moderators you are not going to
get bullied or if someone tries to bully
you we're gonna cut that crap out it's
it's a place for respectful discussion
and I invite you to join us okay let's
now talk about polling
Donald Trump continues to collapse in
the polls and this should really scare
us it should really scare you the people
who want to remove Trump are the ones
who should be most scared by Donald
Trump's polling collapse and this I've
decided I can't not cover the polls
because the polls are remarkable in
terms of how they compare to polls in
past election so I can't not talk about
the polls but the framing has to be the
polls should scare us because they might
keep people home the anti-trump voter
may become complacent if they see too
many of these polls that show Joe Biden
winning so the polls are looking good
for Joe Biden and that should scare us
because we don't want anybody to stay
home as a result the only possible
result of Joe Biden polling well if we
don't take this approach is that some
people who don't like Trump will say I
don't really need to vote I'm just gonna
stay home because but you don't need my
vote Biden's going to win and that's
exactly what we need to dissuade people
from doing so let's take a look at the
latest national polls and then some of
the important state numbers so
nationally Joe Biden is leading Donald
Trump by an average of 8.7 that's a big
lead the polls ranged from leads as
small as four and as large as 14 for Joe
Biden with an average of 8.7 these are
crazy numbers this is a much bigger lead
than Hillary Clinton had and that's why
this is scary to me because this can
change these could be off by the full
margin of error these polls could make
people think I don't need to vote we'll
get back to that looking at the
important battleground states we see
that Arizona has Biden up three and a
half Florida has Biden up five in
Michigan Biden is up seven and a half in
North Carolina Biden is up by three in
New Hampshire Biden's up by four and a
half there's a tie in Ohio a state that
Donald Trump won 2016 in Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin Joe Biden is polling about
six and a half points ahead these are
obviously very good numbers for Joe
if you start with the 2016 map and then
flip to Biden the states where he's now
winning in the polls Joe Biden wins
easily with more than 330 electoral
votes and that's why we should be scared
we cannot afford to have a single person
stay home because they think Biden has
your state in the bag I'll give you an
example and this is an extreme example I
vote in Massachusetts Biden is currently
winning in Massachusetts by 31 points
Trump is not going to win in
Massachusetts but you'd be you had
better be damn sure that I am going to
vote Massachusetts earlier this week I
told you has confirmed vote-by-mail is
available to everybody and they will be
sending out absentee ballot applications
to every registered voter so that's my
view in Massachusetts where Biden's
winning by 31 if you are in any state I
don't care what state you're in you
should imagine your vote visualize your
vote flipping the election from Trump to
Biden okay imagine that that is the
importance of your vote if you knew you
could be the difference maker between
your state going to Trump and Biden I
hope I hope that you would go out and
vote if you want to have a say that's
exactly how you have a say so we're
going to report on polling I'm not going
to ignore the polling story because it
is an interesting story you know an
incumbent president with this low of an
approval rating just four months out
that is news and I'm not going to it
would be weird for me to do a daily show
about mostly about American politics and
not talk about that but the way I'm
going to couch it is we should be scared
by these numbers because the last thing
we want is horrible gut-wrenching
disappointment again on November 3rd or
November 4th or November 10th however
long it takes to count all of those
votes that will be coming in by mail
we're going to continue covering the
polling and asking for your thoughts on
the David Pakman show
Instagram page which is simply david
pakman show all one word on instagram
also if you want to see video people are
loving this
some people went completely crazy riding
in the streets when I posted this video
on my personal Instagram there is a
video of me harvesting my two spicy
peppers these things are so crunchy you
will not believe it ok follow me on
instagram at david hackman's we'll take
quick break and be back right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
welcome back to the show I was scheduled
to have a very interesting interview for
you right now and unfortunately the
guest has very rudely last-minute bailed
on us and if you only knew who this
guest was Barack Obama no just kidding
if you knew who the guest was you'd be
mildly upset that's the the probably the
truth of it so in in order not to delay
the production of today's show I'm gonna
briefly open up the phone lines and hear
from a few people we just had the Donald
Trump tax return decision which I'll be
talking about at the end of the show and
much more so let's go to the phone lines
at six one seven eight three zero 47 50
starting with our caller from the five
five nine area code who's calling today
from five five nine five five nine are
you there caller from five five nine
okay last chance for five five nine and
five fifty nine is gone let's go to our
caller from the two six zero area code
who is calling today from two six oh
yeah who's this sorry when I'm gonna
start with an only fans you said yeah
and only then because I think a great
guy like you would just you know you
know you interestingly enough this may
be shocking to the audience but you're
not the what was your name by the way Oh
Jess you're not the only person Jess who
has suggested I start an only fans but
my understanding is it's essentially
like a porn site isn't it yeah okay and
and you want me to start one okay I'm on
cameo but I'm not on only fans and I
don't know that that's gonna change
anytime soon I'm sorry to disappoint
both men and women apparently who want
me to start that but I I don't see it in
my future Jess
all right very good just seemed totally
serious there that was that was a
serious phone call as far as I can tell
let's go next to our caller from the
seven-one-seven area code who's calling
today from seven one seven hi my name is
Omar hey Omar what's going on and when I
go to the gym like most people aren't
wearing masks and like all the coffee
shops like their ton of people just
sitting there working that is really
like worried about predators virus now I
I share that concern now let me ask you
this Omar if the gym you've identified
as a place that looks dangerous why are
you going to the gym
that's a good question I really love the
gym and it makes you feel a lot better
yeah so I try to go there sparingly when
there's not a lot of people right I
don't know like I go maybe like twice a
week like normally I would have gone
five times a week right back and go no
listen I understand I'm saying my um my
gym just emailed that they're opening on
Monday and workouts will be limited to
90 minutes as if that's a problem for me
right Omar I mean I'm not spending 90
minutes there but um you know you're
gonna you have to wipe down every
machine between use you're not allowed
to hang out and talk to people you have
to have your temperature taken on that
you know when I read the list to me as
like oh yeah it's clearly way too
dangerous it's warm right now I'll just
work out outside or do YouTube workouts
or what that's the call I made but I'm
totally with you I would love to be able
to safely go to the gym yeah they're
like no one's wearing that yeah view I
think it'd be a lot safer if everyone
wore masks absolutely not
absolutely well listen um I guess all we
can do is hope that it improves I I did
go to a coffee shop last weekend and you
know it's an outdoor seating only sort
of thing there were no tables with
within 10 feet of me I posted a picture
of it on my Instagram it that felt safe
and I think I'm just I'm going to only
do things that feel safe the way that
they're being done in my state and so
I'll do outdoor dining I went and got my
our car wore masks the entire time but
I'm gonna pass on the Jim I'm gonna pass
on endure for now okay alright my friend
thank you so much for the call great to
hear from you let's go next to our
caller from the six five zero area code
whose calling today from six five zero
hi hey Jose what's going on
International from from Mexico yep and I
was just wondering whether you managed
to see the new ruling from ice the Trump
administration that is just making it
pretty hard for international students
get back in the States
yeah unless universities bend over
backwards so I did see it III did see it
I'm I'm against the the ruling if you
know how can it be that it's safe enough
to open all elementary and high schools
and yet it is too dangerous to allow a
relatively modest number of
international students to come in it
strikes me as discriminatory like either
it's safe to do schools or it's not as
my take but I heard and I've not read a
lot into this you maybe know more about
this than I do that if schools say that
they've assigned an individual teacher
to you for in-person learning which can
just be like a five-minute check-in per
week that technically then the students
would be allowed to come in have you
heard anything about that yeah we have
to take a certain number of credit hours
as in person or like hybrid right in
order for us to be able to take like the
rest of our course load
online yeah it I mean it just seems to
have a lot of loopholes in it and to me
it just seems like a strategy to get
schools to reopen forcibly because I
just and I mean I'm studying computer
science and like I can't imagine the
computer science department at my
university operating without
international students
right like they're the DA's they are at
like they worked student offices like I
did it yeah it's just it's very
draconian that seems counterproductive
well it seems to me that either way it
will give the attempt the Trump
administration's something that they
like either they will keep keep a bunch
of foreigners out that's one possibility
and they would welcome that or it would
get schools to reopen even when they
don't really think it's the right thing
to do which is also what the Trump
administration wants so it's almost like
they're gonna get something they like
out of this no I agreed what do you
think of the end game of of opening
schools it just seems like a bomb ready
to explode like you get you have a bunch
of cases individual household you send
all the kids to the same place I'll get
infected and then they all go back home
yeah I think the I think basically the
the hope is the bomb won't go off until
after November 3rd like I think the
calculation is schools won't I believe
that no schools open earlier than late
August here in Massachusetts it's
usually September I think there's some
states that open earlier I think the
calculation is if we get schools open we
get the publicity of schools being open
parents are able to go back to their
jobs maybe because they're not home
watching their kids so the economy will
show some better jobs numbers and
hopefully it'll all stay relatively
under control until November 3rd and
it'll get Trump reelected I don't think
it'll work I mean if you look at we it's
right now as we're filming this it's the
early afternoon we already are at 25,000
new cases today it's only halfway
through the day most states don't report
until the afternoon like it seems like
it's not going to work but I think
that's their idea it's crazy it's crazy
all right my friend I hope it works out
and I appreciate you letting me know
what's going on take care of likewise
the pleasure is all on this side of the
microphone let's go to our caller from
the 6 7 8 air
who's calling today from six seven eight
hey David um my name is Anthony hey
Anthony do you hear me yeah I got okay
um so my question is with Kanye West
presidential announcement do you think
there's any chance that he gets on the
debate stage and if so what do you think
the dynamic would be with him sound and
Biden all up on there no so listen
here's the deal
Kanye West has said that he struggles
with bipolar disorder it's very clear
that Kanye West is quite ill I saw some
reports in the last 24 to 48 hours that
he's in the middle of a bipolar episode
right now I don't know if that's true
but it's being alleged I don't I I think
that this is a complete distraction I
don't think black folks are going to
vote for I don't think black folks are
gonna switch their vote to Kanye because
Kanye happens to be black I just don't
even want to give this attention he's
not going to be on the debate stage to
my knowledge he's not done any of the
things to actually formally be running
for president I think it's just nonsense
and I don't want to risk distracting
from the very real danger of not
removing Donald Trump in November which
needs to be you know Biden's the guy
that can win and we've got to remove
Trump yeah somewhat it looks like I
think you might just back out in a few
weeks or so I think this is just a
moment yeah and again back out as far as
I know you get like I can say I'm
running for president if I don't
actually go through the process of
formalizing that am I really running for
president like there's nothing for him
to even back out of yet yeah all right
Anthony very good great to hear from you
and an important opportunity to mention
I think Kanye West is ill and I don't
think we should pay too much attention
to it let's go next to our caller from
the 8 for 7 area code who's calling
today from 8 for 7 hey David it's not
you I great I'm a proud new member and
I'm so happy to be talking you love the
show Thank You Eli I appreciate that so
a couple things that I want to actually
help answer for your last caller okay um
the public my kids are 13 and 11 and the
school system just sent out something
saying we have the option to keep them
home there may be only certain days to
go to school or there may be an
e-learning only option so I don't even
know that they're not really gonna open
the public school what what what state
is this in Eli where are you located
okay got it got it yeah I mean listen I
think that did this is much like with
the shutdown's which is Donald Trump
likes to pretend that he's the boss and
he tells the 50 states what to do but
these are decisions that are probably
going to vary dramatically between
states and even within states I imagine
that there will be parts of states and
school districts that say we're going to
do this or we're going to do that the
idea that Trump is going to be running
the decisions for all of these school
districts is a fantasy yeah it's pretty
much I think governor pressure here is
doing a wonderful job and that's why
they monitor it so in case they need to
pull back they're not gonna put anyone
at risk especially like my family we all
have as well unfortunately yeah and then
the other thing I was gonna say about
the Kanye thing is he's calling Forbes
magazine in Elon Musk is kind of pushing
him here he's trying to call his party
the birthday parties and claiming if you
get a vaccine for corona virus it's the
mark of the beast so I don't think he's
gonna be getting anybody to vote yeah
Kanye's comments about vaccines were
crazy but but to get back to something
that's much more relevant though than
Kanye so if what is you have you decided
your kids aren't going into school or
what what or are you going to wait to
see what the school district decides I
have a feeling what's gonna end up
coming down with the district is you
know they're very aware of children with
allergies or autoimmune diseases that
it's gonna come down to they're gonna do
a risk assessment from the top down and
recommend to parents or maybe mandated
saying your child's probably should be
in an e-learning situation or a remote
learning situation versus coming in
because it's too dangerous for them so
you you think that they may say certain
kids will come come in but we'll have
fewer people in the classroom by taking
kids with with conditions that may make
them more at risk and they can do
eLearning I
I have a feeling that's where it's
interesting interesting alright what was
so Mike yeah Oh David my I was just
actually coming last to callers my main
question was actually about what you had
said when you were talking about beating
black lives matter Oh Jason I'm Jewish
too and Terry Crews was trying to get
into it with with Don Lemon but nobody
is really letting anybody talk about
what the founders at the movement the
actual doctrine is so I don't know why
they're just not letting people know and
understand yeah there's good people in
the movement but I don't think people
understand what is being dictated from
the top down or what the ultimate goals
are yeah and again we you can argue the
top down doesn't matter because it's a
sort of a leaderless organization but
the point the point I've made before is
there's a lot of individual black lives
matter groups saying you know that this
we've got to fight against Jewish
supremacy in the israeli-palestinian
conflict and our battle is the same
battle that the Palestinians are
fighting it's like listen check out my
clips about the israeli-palestinian
conflict you will find that that I have
a you know measured take on what is
going on but it is not the same battle
there's a lot of anti-semitism within
black lives matter and the women's March
which we talked about previously and so
I'm right there about structural racism
in the United States I'm right there
about all of these different issues but
to say this is this is the same battle
the Palestinians are fighting against
Israelis it's like no it's not and
you're gonna lose a lot of people if
people are paying attention you're gonna
lose a lot of people with that argument
yeah they just don't understand the
history of the conflict and how it's
been going on for absolutely wait wait
wait you long but I just want to say
thank you for everything you do I keep
telling everybody to check out the show
and they're doing like I did please I
mean I'm an out-of-work contractor for
instructional design and education
however I can definitely afford with the
discounts to get your show on the air
keep keep it going
thank you in a great job and we love
watching you every day man Eli I
appreciate it
say hi to everybody there in the Chicago
area and hope it all works out with the
school year yeah
and you take care of seeing safe happy
and healthy and keep up the good work of
the show it's amazing all right thank
you very much in an early shabbat
shalom' my friend thank you so much okay
let's go next to our caller from the
nine one four area code who's calling
today from nine one four hi this is ryan
did you say ryan yeah hi
so mike my question is about the lincoln
project i'm sorry if you've already
covered it on the show and i just missed
it but there's this group a Lincoln
project that's putting out ads and I
think they're really really effective
ads I was wondering if you had any
comment on them yes a Lincoln project is
anti-trump Republicans it includes
Kellyanne Conway's husband George Conway
I believe Steve Schmidt former McCain
adviser is involved Rick Wilson who's
been a guest on this program longtime
Republican strategist isn't but there's
a bunch of others but those are like the
three big ones am i right well in any
case they've been producing anti Trump
ads I mean listen the ads are very good
I don't know
you know when I see the ad it reinforces
the beliefs I already have but I don't
know if it's changing any minds so to
speak but to the extent that they have
money and these are Republicans who
recognize the danger of Donald Trump
it's great the ads are very good and
we've reviewed a couple of them on the
program before uh yeah and I I also
wanted to point out a particular ads
that I thought was they blew my mind cuz
I've never seen anything like it yeah
they have this one ad called whispers
that's the name of it on the YouTube
video and it seems like whispers is
intended just to be seen by Donald Trump
and it's just meant to throw him into
tilt if you haven't seen that ad
whispers is a really crazy ad I I think
that actually you know I mentioned
before I don't know how many minds are
being changed by these ads I actually
think you're onto something which is the
ads are very well calibrated to trigger
Donald Trump himself and he has gone on
tweet storms as a result of not always
the ad itself but the fallout from these
ads and that I think is actually a
really
clever aspect to it because a lot of the
damage that has that Trump has suffered
has been self-inflicted damage like
nobody said he had to fail on
coronavirus he could have taken it
seriously it was to some degree it's
self-inflicted not the virus the virus
would have been here either way but
Trump's reaction so I think the ads are
good in that and in that way that they
triggered Trump yeah yeah uh we've never
seen anything like what we're seeing
before all right my friend thank you so
much for the call I appreciate it
we are in uncharted territory I think is
the way I would put it thanks to
everybody who called in was just taking
a few brief phone calls but I do want to
go to a break because the news has just
broken about the Supreme Court decision
on Donald Trump's taxes and that's what
I'm going to talk about right after this
short break the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
okay in a much awaited decision the
Supreme Court just moments ago decided
72 that Donald Trump cannot ignore a
subpoena of his financial records sought
by New York prosecutors and the wording
that I selected to tell you that is not
trivial and I'm going to explain it to
you momentarily so zoomed out this is a
big legal defeat for Donald Trump at the
same time his lawyer is calling it a
victory in that he is saying now they
can fight this out at a lower court and
yet Donald Trump is also Simon
simultaneously going absolutely crazy on
Twitter and we're going to walk through
all of it so let's start with the
decision itself there's some confusion
because there were actually two
decisions made here and also the
decision is about whether this now goes
back to a lower court to be fought so
what the Supreme Court said today is
that the path is legally cleared for
prosecutors to seek Donald Trump's
financial records at the lower court
level a lower court previously found
that Donald Trump is not immune from
responding to subpoenas because he is
President of the United States that's
really the big decision here because for
a while Donald Trump and his lawyers and
others have argued it's not just that
Trump is immune from indictment Donald
Trump is immune from investigation by
virtue of being President of the United
States and therefore he doesn't even
have to respond to a subpoena for his
financial records what the court found
in a 7 to 2 decision is that Trump is
not immune from investigation and that's
actually a really big deal however this
now means that it goes back to a lower
court and what Trump's lawyer is saying
is okay well I mean you know framing it
as positively as possible now we go back
to the lower court to keep working to
fight these records from being provided
on other grounds and of course prevent
them from going public and the the
second part of the Supreme Court
decision Congress was also seeking
Donald Trump's financial records for now
the Supreme Court has said prosecutors
can seek Trump's records you've got to
figure it out but Congress for now is
not going to trump is not going to be
compelled to provide financial records
to Congress so this is I mean listen if
you want me to - just give you the
highlight we're not going to see Trump's
taxes before the election right we have
four months until the election what has
been decided is that on principle Trump
can't just ignore the subpoena from
prosecutors but now it's going to be
fought at the lower court if indeed
Trump has to provide his financial
records it's not going to be done public
it will have to be kept quiet at least
and certainly beyond the November
election so if your idea was based on
this decision we might see Trump's taxes
before November not going to happen now
Trump is going crazy on Twitter he
immediately started tweeting
uncontrollably as soon as this decision
went public and I'm gonna go through
some of those tweets Trump starting with
quote the Supreme Court sends case back
to lower court arguments to continue
this is all a political prosecution I
won the Moller witch-hunt that's the one
that said it couldn't clear Trump on
obstruction I won the Malheur witch-hunt
and others and now I have to keep
fighting in a politically corrupt New
York not fair to this presidency or
administration he's the victim he's the
most powerful person in the world maybe
and yet he's the victim
everybody's unfair to him he just he q
it's all just stacked against him from
continuing with another tweet saying
quote courts in the past have given
broad deference but not to me again he's
the victim he's being singled out the
courts are singling him everybody's just
singling him out poor Trump and then a
three tweet rant where Trump said quote
we have a totally corrupt previous
administration including a president and
vice president who spied on my campaign
and got kite I guess he meant caught I
got kite and nothing happens to them
this crime was taking place even before
my election everyone knows it and he had
all her frozen stiff with fear one
against one all against the federal
government and the Democrats send
everything to politically corrupt in New
York I'm struggling to parse the grammar
which is falling apart with everyone
leaving to give it a second third and
fourth try now the Supreme Court gives a
delay ruling that they would never have
given for another president this is
about all caps prosecutorial misconduct
we catch the other side spying on my
campaign the biggest political crime and
scandal in US history and nothing
happens but despite this I have done
more than any president in history in
first three and a half years there might
be are there six lies there are could
might there even be seven lies or
distorts it's crazy what is going on and
again if his lawyer considers this a
victory why is Trump going so crazy but
the important takeaway is Trump is not
immune from investigation that's good
it's a good thing the court has
clarified that but we are not going to
see Donald Trump's taxes before November
and we all need to accept that that is
the case the good news is we don't need
to see Trump's taxes to know he has to
be removed whether we see Trump's taxes
or not we know that Trump has to be
removed in November so this isn't going
to complicate voting for me if you
understand what I'm saying okay for the
second day in a row exactly as the
time-lag hypothesis would predict Texas
set another single day death record
yesterday remember that cases started
spiking in Texas around mid to later
June like June 16th to 18th we
anticipate typically a 19 to 21 day lag
time between cases and deaths and so if
cases start to spike between June 16 and
18 we would expect deaths to spike right
now and that's exactly what
happened we had a then single day death
record in Texas of 85 deaths on Tuesday
and then yesterday an even bigger number
of 50% bigger 121 deaths yesterday so
this does not bode well for the next 10
days because of the new cases were
actually twice as high last week in
Texas than they were back in mid-june
very very ugly also notable that Florida
the other state along with Arizona and
California that's seeing huge numbers of
cases Florida today as of noon had
already gotten a new single day death
record only as of noon so things are
looking very very bad now meanwhile in
Oklahoma you might remember that Donald
Trump had a rally in Tulsa Oklahoma a
couple of weeks ago Oklahoma set a new
case record yesterday with 858 cases in
one day which probably is not coming as
a shock to too many people so what's
important about this is that when we saw
the cases start to spike but not the
deaths the most easy explanation the
most easy the easiest argument to make
was there's a lag between cases and
deaths it's about 20 days there were
other ideas thrown out and I've
mentioned some of these ideas to you
before it's it's younger people getting
the virus so the deaths aren't going to
spike because young people tend not to
be as affected by the virus we're doing
more testing meaning that on average the
people being tested are healthier so
even though there are more cases being
reported we're not actually going to see
as many as many people died States could
be lying and it's still not clear that
states are being totally transparent and
that you know all these different ideas
the virus has mutated and become less
serious it's sadly and tragically is
looking more and more like the
explanation is the simplest one which is
cases started going up sometime between
June 16 and June 20 depending on the
state and 20 days later which is now
we're starting to see the deaths spike
now meanwhile and I'm going to have more
coverage of this on tomorrow's program
meanwhile Donald Trump wants kids back
in school he wants all kids back in
school in person despite the medical
community saying this isn't safe despite
public health officials expressing
concern about sending all kids back to
school despite a number of summer camps
having to be shut down because so many
people so many kids have gotten the
virus including in I believe it's
Arkansas Missouri and one other state at
least has had to shut down summer camps
and the projection coming out of Donald
Trump's mouth lately is truly stunning
he said earlier this week that states
are keeping politically are keeping
schools closed for political reasons he
even tweeted yesterday quote in Germany
Denmark Norway Sweden and many other
countries schools are open with no
problems the Dems think it would be bad
for them politically if US schools
opened before the November election but
is important for the children and
families may cut off funding if not open
now Sweden aside Sweden's having
problems the other countries Trump
mentions dealt with coronavirus the
reason that schools are opening in those
countries is they have so few cases
Germany Denmark and Norway had at most a
couple hundred or new cases a day
recently or even like in the teens or
just double digits we have 60 thousand
new cases a day so if you want to be
doing what Europe is doing you should
have handled coronavirus like Europe did
from the beginning now I also can't
ignore that Donald Trump is threatening
schools with pulling funding if they
don't open Trump said he doesn't want to
make this political he said that earlier
this week he says he believes schools
are being kept closed for political
reasons but Trump has identified that he
believes schools are being kept kept
closed to hurt him so Trump is now
saying we don't want to make it
political but we're gonna force you to
reopen schools under penalty of pulling
funding because he believes it will help
his re-election if schools are open
that's making it political which he
claims schools are actually doing
consider also this incredible hypocrisy
if it's too dangerous for Paul Manafort
and Michael Cohen to be in prison
because of coronavirus how is it safe to
reopen every school and I know some of
you will say but David Michael Cohen is
is not an old
but he's older than kids Paul Manafort
is even older I think man affords in his
70s kids are not as at risk when it
comes to spreading and serious cases of
coronavirus as people Paul man affords
age that is true but what about the
teachers what about the parents and tens
of millions of children going back to
school are going to put millions of
adults at risk and and I want to be
really clear I get economically the
importance of opening schools a lot of
parents can't work if their kids aren't
in school because they can't just afford
childcare so even if every single day
you know full-time childcare so even if
the job has reopened for the parent they
may be unable to work if their kids
aren't in school I get it but we have to
be sensible if schools had to close when
there were 100,000 active cases in the
United States how can you say they
should open when we have a million and a
half active cases in the United States
which is roughly where we are estimated
to be right now I'm struggling with the
math of it and tomorrow on the program
at the top of the show tomorrow because
of the Supreme Court decision on Trump's
taxes we just ran out of time
tomorrow we're going to talk more about
the case for opening or not opening
schools hey this is really funny we have
a voicemail number that number is two
one nine two david p there's this guy
the egg man he's a liberal Jewish guy up
in in upstate New York who calls into
the show he said he tried watching
NASCAR because he heard you know that's
Trump said the ratings are ratings are
down he wanted to see what it was all
about it doesn't seem like he's going to
be a big NASCAR fan take a listen to
what the egg man said hey Dave I
consider myself pretty liberal and my
wife is like intellectual liberal way
beyond me last Sunday we watched our
first NASCAR race ever because I learned
that there was a black guy named Bubba
Wallace that's a NASCAR driver
Ryland some guy had a black lives matter
car and I also learned that they got rid
of the Confederate flag and banded so I
think their ratings have gone up and I
watched my first race ever now I never
will again it was really stupid but
unless I tried to do it again all these
good polls against
trumpet for Biden are just going to make
us more disappointed if Trump wins yeah
I am I do not want to be so let down
again Dave I really don't need to do
what's up
give me a break somebody called about
dual size she definitely doesn't listen
to yourself hey Shalom brother awesome
garden I wish I could show you mine but
you know I can't tell yep
Tulsa Oklahoma yes of course all good
points by the egg man very very
compelling we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about how
many households missed their July first
housing payments it's a huge number
we're going to talk about Portland
approving a cap on how much those food
delivery apps can charge restaurants and
we'll also talk about the latest Corona
meltdown relating to somebody losing
their job all of those stories and much
much more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
join cockman calm